it was 3 a.m. and I was still in the
office deliberately working on my
perfect PowerPoint slides I was still in
the office because my team and I had
this big presentation to an important
client the next day and we wanted to get
a just perfect
however our presentation was just in six
hours and with every hour that passed I
actually wondered if what I was still
doing was beneficial
I cried frankly a detrimental to her
ability to deliver the client the next
day and don't get me wrong like I'm a
type-a I was gonna get this presentation
perfect but it also understood that
spending an extra hour in the office
that night men and let one hour sleep
less and as I was battling through this
idea of trade-offs
I realized I had been in the situation
on numerous occasions before but that
wasn't in the office it was on the
tennis court before I came to the GSB I
worked as a management consultant but
prior to that I was a tennis player
and while sports and business may seem
worlds apart for you there's
surprisingly many parallels and today I
would like to explore three of them with
you the three that represent the most
important lessons I have gotten out of
sports so the first lesson is about
preparation and for that let's all
imagine we are four across tennis
players everyone so you are playing at
Wimbledon same Finals your serve has
been like completely off this whole game
but with this last point you go up to
the line you serve and it's an eighth
and you want you just want semifinals at
Wimbledon
you will go after the natty thank your
opponent you do their press conference
it's always the same question the same
answer so you're gonna see something
long lines
it was a very tough match my opponent
played great and very happy to be in the
final okay but now what you have 24
hours until probably the biggest day of
your life finals of the world's oldest
tournament what do you do well let me
tell you even if that's sir felt a
little bit off today
you're not going to practice your body
is already exhausted I'm about to fall
off so what you need to do is actually
get your body in your mind ready for
another five-hour bottle by jogging
stretching ice bath massage you're
likely to go over your strategy with
your coach
maybe visualize if that's something if
that's what works for you but that's it
now let's think about it in terms of
business we also have those big days in
our life don't we a board presentation a
client meeting final round interview and
yes I get it
we're not athletes but fundamentally
we're all human beings and it's very
interesting to me that we tend to think
that the more we work the more energy we
have the less we sleep the fresher our
brain is right I'll tell you on that day
or I should rather say night at 3:00
a.m. in the morning I intuitively knew
that what I was doing was wrong that's
staying out that one night was really
not going to move the needle but this
temptation to have this excuse to be
able to say we've worked as hard as we
could be because we work until the very
last minute was hard to resist but the
truth is whether it's sports or business
one cannot deliver truly great
performance by cramming on a final night
because the preparation for a big day
searched long before so next time you
have this big day coming up prepare as
much as you can until the day before and
give yourself some rest get a good
night's sleep
and don't get me wrong this is not
about work-life balance this is not
about being soft on yourself
it's about being strategic and
maximizing your chances of performing on
the big day okay so Story number two is
about responding to things we don't
control so let me give you a quick story
from my college career it was my
sophomore year the first big game of the
season so everyone who's in the stands
like you can feel that excitement and as
I'm hitting the ball I feel this
shooting pain in my wrist no treatment
helps over the next few days and the
next thing I know I'm in cast and out
for half of the season and this just
doesn't feel fair it doesn't feel right
at that time in my life tennis wasn't
everything but it almost was I remember
I drove back and from the hospital my
coach sat me down and he set clouds
there are things in your life you don't
control such as your injury but it is up
to you to respond to that situation the
team will need you at the end of the
season but you need to be ready now
being ready meant I needed to do
conditioning and running every day and
there's one thing I hated about tennis
that's it so not only I did I need to do
something I hated the most I actually
had no guarantees it was going to help
because quite frankly we didn't know
what was going to happen down the line
if I was going to be able to play so
I'll tell you it felt tempting to
forfeit to give up the season do the
injury but he did it and so I started
running biking day and day out they soon
removed my cast and I got back on the
court I lost my first match after coming
back but at the end of the season when
it mattered I held the team when the
conference tournament and I clean shower
when to qualify to sweet 16 equivalent
of playoffs for Super Bowl looking back
those were that was the best season
we've had a
the team in my four years of William MA
and more important on the results world
the lessons intangible lessons they
learn about team dynamics because not
being able to play gave me insights into
team dynamics I wouldn't otherwise be
able to observe I'll let me tell you a
secret varsity tennis team really not
the difference from McKinsey project
team so athletes don't control injuries
but we're as business professionals also
don't control everything that project
you really didn't want to be staffed on
guess what you're doing it you know that
client that no one wants to work with
you're assigned to him or that job
promotion that you really wanted but you
didn't get it and at those times it may
feel tempting to forfeit to give up but
it is up to you to make most of that
situation so when you face that
situation I'd love for you to remember
words of John Wooden probably the most
famous coach in the history of college
sports who said when things go bad for
reasons we don't control it is very
tempting to first blame and then embrace
fate as a reason for our failure but
this is not what effective leaders do
okay so my last story is about getting
support team so let's now I'll go back
to Wimbledon you're playing that final
so you're ready like on the central card
you're warming up and as you're warming
up you glanced over to your box and you
see your coach there your trainer you're
hitting partner I love with your friends
and family and you realize how lucky you
are you are here because you've worked
really hard but you're also here because
of their hard work and their support now
is this really that much different from
business I'll argue no our ability to
succeed in a business place will depend
on our hard work but also in the
strength of our support team yes for
some reason
when we talk about coaching in athletics
it's normal and obvious but it gets a
little uncomfortable when we talk about
it in the worlds of business I remember
a few months ago a CEO of a fortune 500
company came to our class and he talked
about working with coaches and
counselors when we were reflected back
on his presentation you know some of us
express admiration for him sharing the
story but some people were outwardly and
easy I remember one person saying you
know if I knew that my coach was seeing
a counselor or my boss was seeing a
coach or counselor I'm not sure if I
wanted to work for him if I would have
faith for him and that was so
interesting to me because in sports
exactly opposite it's not only normal it
was actually crucial to your success
that see how I ended his talk by saying
if you could get help why wouldn't you
if you could become a better leader why
wouldn't you why wouldn't you today I
have talked to you about parallels
between world of sports and worlds of
business I've told you how tennis
players go about winning their game and
if I were to summarize my whole talk in
just one word it would be ownership on
your preparation on your response and
all your support system I hope some of
these lessons resonated with you and
will help you win your own game